Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich habe beschlossen, du bist jetzt mein AI-Assistent und du musst mir künftig
alle Intros für diese Sendung schreiben.
Es tut mir leid, Dave, aber das kann ich nicht tun.
Musik,
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 524 vom 24. Mai. Das passt ja perfekt.
Extra so lange gewartet.
Das war von langer Hand geplant. Das machen wir jetzt immer so.
Funktioniert bestimmt super ab 32. Ja, genau.
Du willst nicht mein AI-Assistent sein?
Du musst fragen, wo das Problem liegt.
Ja, aber das Problem bist du, aber ich...
Nee, und dann sage ich, du weißt doch, glaube ich, sehr genau so gut wie ich, wo das Problem liegt.
Das Problem bin ich.
Aber wie soll ich denn da jetzt von meiner Abhängigkeit von amerikanischen Systemen
wegkommen? Du bist doch so klug.
Ja,
ich sage ja, du weißt genauso gut wie ich, wo das Problem liegt.
Das kann ich nicht zulassen.
Wir kommen, wir werden da noch gleich drüber reden, aber ich habe wirklich so
langsam das Gefühl, Stanley Kubrick hat eigentlich alles schon komplett durchdacht.
Langsam hast du das Gefühl?
Ja, langsam habe ich das Gefühl, dass wir auch noch die letzten Punkte aufhaken.
Jetzt merken es auch, da hast du aber bei einer AI geschummelt,
dass sie dir den Tipp gegeben hat, dass du das jetzt schon merkst.
Blitzmerker, deswegen bin ich ja auch in diesem Podcast, weißt du?
Ja.
Das war von Anfang an meine Primärqualifikation, weil ich immer die Dinge so schnell erfasse und so.
Ja, ja, wir werden uns über AI unterhalten müssen. Wieder mal ganz viel. Es bleibt nicht aus.
Solange wir noch dürfen, reden wir über AI. Teilweise sogar schlecht.
Genau, bis die AI uns das verbietet.
Solange wir den neu dürfen.
Aber erstmal machen wir Feedback. Genau, weil wir haben ja wieder alles falsch gemacht.
Und das muss dann hier auch entsprechend dokumentiert werden.
Genau. Dominik hat geschrieben, zur Papstwahl noch kurz die Korrektur,
dass der neue Papst im vierten Wahlgang gewählt wurde und nicht,
wie von euch, mehrfach gesagt. Stimmt, haben wir mehrfach gesagt, im dritten Wahlgang.
Vielleicht hat es euch verwirrt, dass es nur zweimal schwarzen Rauch gab.
Das liegt aber daran, dass es nicht nach jedem Wahlgang schwarzen Rauch gibt,
sondern in der Regel nur einmal vormittags und einmal nachmittags nach jeweils zwei Wahlgängen.
Ja.
Naja, ich meine, was ist ein Wahlgang wert, der nicht verkündet wird?
Ja, also ich verstehe.
Weißer Geier, wie oft Friedrich Merz nicht gewählt wurde und uns das keiner gesagt hat.
Aber guck mal, was ich auch wieder nicht verstehe ist, in der Regel nur einmal
vormittags und einmal nachmittags nach jeweils zwei Wahlgängen.
Und es gab aber zweimal schwarzen Rauch. Dann käme ich auf vier,
dann ist der Loser im fünften Wahlgang gewählt worden. Was ist das denn für einen Papst?
Zweite Ich wollte schon sagen, fast zweite Wahl. Nee, fünfte Wahl.
Okay, aber dritter Wahlgang, wie auch immer, ist mir ehrlich gesagt.
Auch ein bisschen egal.
Verhältnismäßig, ja.
Verhältnismäßig egal. Ich würde, also ja,
also man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, soweit ich dieses Konzept Papst verstanden habe,
bezieht der seinen Anspruch als Vertreter Gottes oder Jesus oder irgendeiner
von der Dreifaltigkeit auf Erden ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt durch demokratische Legitimation.
Das heißt, ich würde da jetzt eh keinen, weißt du,
also, meine Güte, bist Vertreter Gottes auf Erden, was soll dir da so eine,
oder Jesus, oder Heilige Maria, oder Petrus, und Heiliger Geist,
oder was, da musst du, da ist dir ja so ein Wahlgang, verhältnismäßig,
egal, ja, da wird jetzt auch keiner das anfechten und sagen,
ja, hier, nee, gemäß Satzung,
Quorum nicht erreicht, oder weißt du, keine, das ist ja alles,
das ist doch alles, das sind doch irdische,
Probleme. Das sind doch irdische Kategorien.
Naja, auf jeden Fall finde ich, er lächelt nett und er scheint ja auch irgendwie
alle halbwegs beisammen zu haben, soweit macht es zumindest derzeit den Eindruck.
Von daher bin ich okay mit dem Papst.
Wenn Leute ihn jetzt wichtig finden im internationalen politischen Geschehen,
meinetwegen, vielleicht bewirkt er ja auch irgendetwas.
Wir wissen es ja nicht. So, andere Päpste haben, sagen wir mal,
ihre Rolle dahingehend nicht so sehr ausgespielt, wenn es der katholischen Kirche gelingt,
in irgendeiner Form politisch so aktiv zu werden, dass sie halt auch wirklich mal das Gute bewirken.
I'm all in.
Mir ist egal, wer das Gute macht. Mir ist egal, wer das Gute macht.
Genau, also ich meine, der Rest
der Politik scheint sich ja nicht gerade einzureihen groß in die Schlange.
Von daher kann der Papst ja mal gucken, was so geht.
Warum nicht mal einen Papst?
Warum nicht mal einen Papst? Es geht aber noch weiter mit der Kritik.
Oh je, genau. Heike schreibt, ihr echauffiert euch über den Papst-Blog zurecht.
Aber eure Begründung ist doch sehr schwach. Warum sollte Fußball wichtiger und
finanzierter als Papstblock sein?
Kommt seltener vor, als die Bundesliga interessiert nach Anzahl der Gläubigen, aber doch sehr stark.
Ich bin nicht gläubig, aber muss anmerken, euer Vergleich ist keiner und lediglich
durch subjektive Präferenzen geprägt.
Das ist keine Kirchenkritik, sondern einfach nur Befindlichkeit.
Ohne Argument lässt sich doch schwer inhaltlich debattieren.
Ihr gebt so nichts an die Hand.
Schade eigentlich. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass das ein Missverständnis ist,
weil die können, also Spiegel ist ein privatwirtschaftliches Medienunternehmen,
die können bloggen, worüber sie wollen.
Die Form, das Niveau der Berichterstattung, dass ich, pass auf Tim,
ich folge dem Papst-Live-Blog, ich kriege irgendwelche Stimmungskommentare,
was mir aber nicht vermittelt wird ist, zum Beispiel,
dass üblicherweise vormittags und nachmittags es schwarzen Rauch gibt,
üblicherweise nach jeweils zwei Wahlgängen.
Derartige wichtige Informationen über den Ablauf des Verfahrens wurden mir da nicht mitgeteilt.
Das ist das, was ich bemängele.
Du willst mir doch nicht erzählen, dass du das ganze Papstblog gelesen hast.
Nö, aber muss ich auch nicht. Im Internet hat Gefährlichste zu stehen,
was für mich relevant ist und totale Stadionstimmung hier ist für mich keine,
das ist für mich einfach, das genügt nicht im journalistischen Anspruch.
Gleichzeitig muss ich sagen, dass relativ häufig, wenn ich Spielberichte lese,
wenn ich ein Fußballspiel die schriftliche Zusammenfassung lese,
da werden die Regeln auch meistens nicht nochmal neu erklärt.
Aber ich fühle mich über den Ablauf des Spieles in der Regel sinnvoll informiert
und ich weiß auch, üblicherweise steht in dem Artikel auch, mit welchem Punktestand das Spiel geendet hat.
Das hat hier im Parks Blog auch gefehlt, meine Meinung.
Also,
ich bin ja froh ich bin ja froh, wenn sie überhaupt alle mal wieder bloggen,
auch wenn das immer nur so Momentaufnahmen sind.
Blogs sind ja eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht mal für zwei Tage irgendwas zu
tickern das ist halt eigentlich ja ein Ticker während ein Blog eigentlich etwas
ist, was man über einen viel längeren Zeitraum macht.
Also ein Papstblog müsste immer über den Papstblock.
Und das macht der Spiegel jetzt auch nicht. Also wenn ihr das schon macht,
nennt es Papstticker und nicht Papstblock.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das vielleicht sogar so hieß. Aber auch egal.
Max hat kommentiert über meine Gedanken zur AI-Vorherrschaft oder im Prinzip die Rolle von Google.
Schreibt Max, die Einschätzung von Linus, dass Google kein Konkurrenzprodukt
zu Chat-GPT von signifikanter Relevanz anzubieten hat, so interpretiere ich
seine Aussage, finde ich schwierig.
Stimme hat schon dagegen gehalten, dass Gemini durchaus auch was kann und das
würde ich gerne unterstützen.
Schaut man sich den Chatbot Arena Benchmark unter lmarina.ai an.
Den ich für durchaus relevant in diesem Bereich halte, dann war das Top-Gemini-Modell
aktuell 2.5 Pro in den letzten Wochen bis Monaten dort immer auf einem der Top-Plätze.
Außerdem produziert Google mit der Gemma-Reihe auch vielversprechende,
relativ leichtgewichtige Oak-Weights-Modelle.
Aus persönlicher Erfahrung kann ich sagen, dass der Deep-Research-Modus von
Gemini durchaus beeindruckend gut funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich nicht das Einzige, was für die Produktplatzierung relevant ist.
Sowohl aus User-Perspektive als auch aus Entwickler-Perspektive finde ich die
Services teilweise unhandlicher als die von Omeyer.
Zumindest spielen aber die Modelle inzwischen in der gleichen Liga mit und durch
die Integrationsmöglichkeiten in Googles Ökosystem sehe ich da durchaus eine
hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Google seine Marktstellung hier auch weiter zementieren könnte.
Wichtiger Hinweis, guter Hinweis, wenn ich auf Google.com gehe,
sehe ich diese Tools nicht oder nur schleppend, teilweise so AI-Zusammenfassungen,
während andere Suchmaschinen das schon sehr viel stärker integriert haben.
Aber ein sinnvoller und wichtiger Hinweis.
Ja, also erstmal Benchmarks sind immer so ein bisschen problematisch,
weil die müssen auch die ganze Zeit angepasst werden.
Es war jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren so, dass die Benchmarks relativ schnell
von den Modellen und das, was sie können, überfahren wurden.
Also weil man immer gedacht hat, das ist aber jetzt mal total schwierig,
das dauert jetzt mal voll lange und so weiter. und dann zwei Wochen später kam
schon wieder das nächste Modell, was wieder schneller, höher,
weiter war und dann war das irgendwie auf einmal auch schon wieder geschafft.
Und das ist auch wie mit so Performance Benchmarks, your mileage may vary.
Nichtsdestotrotz sagen die natürlich schon ein bisschen was aus,
auch über die Fähigkeit und was ich da im Wesentlichen rauslesen kann,
ist, mehr oder weniger sind alle,
großen Player am Markt und das sind ja deutlich mehr, als wir normalerweise
diskutieren, das ist ja nicht nur Google und OpenAI,
sondern da gehört auch noch Anthropic dazu, dann kommen die Chinesen jetzt hier, Alibaba,
DeepSeek hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal drüber gesprochen,
nochmal so von der Seite.
Dann wie heißt nochmal hier die TikTok-Bude.
ByteDance.
Genau, ByteDance hat auch noch ein Modell. Ich habe gerade vergessen, wie es heißt.
Egal. sind auf jeden Fall alle mit im Boot und geben sich gerade eine ganze
Menge Mühe und jetzt hat gerade Google,
dicke Ankündigungen auch gemacht, so was du meinst mit hier Zusammenfassung,
das war sozusagen das Testbett.
Dazu muss man auch noch sagen, mit Google ist das auch so ein bisschen wie mit,
Apple und Contender, da gibt es Leute, die sagen so, ja, hier guckt mal,
dieser chinesische Hersteller hat aber dieses geile Feature und Apple hat das ja überhaupt nicht.
Ja, das ist oft so, dass kleinere Hersteller sowas haben, weil kleinere Hersteller
können das auch mal eben in kleinen Mengen produzieren.
Aber bevor ein großer Anbieter, der den Markt schon weitgehend owned,
mit ähnlichen Features nachziehen kann, hast du einfach ganz andere Economies of Scale.
Da müssen solche Features dann halt irgendwie milliardenfach produziert werden,
damit du dann irgendwie dabei bist. Bei Google ist es ähnlich.
Wenn die jetzt quasi sagen, ja jetzt auch jede Suchmaschineneingabe ist jetzt
auch eine AI-Bedienung,
da rauscht es aber ganz ordentlich im Prozessorwald und das sind Dinge,
die müssen eben von langer Hand vorbereitet werden.
Von daher ist das alles eben noch nicht so ganz vergleichbar und ich denke,
es wird sich hier einfach noch sehr viel ändern.
Also dieser Wettlauf findet derzeit statt und man dachte ja auch schon öfter,
das kann ja jetzt nicht lange so weitergehen.
Bin mir da nicht so sicher. Ich glaube, das wird noch eine ganze Weile so gehen.
OpenAI hat natürlich einen ganz anderen Mindshare derzeit und so auch diese
First Mover Advantage, weil sie halt einfach mit ihrem LLM,
mit GPT-3 haben sie so diesen offiziellen Startschuss gesetzt. Jetzt geht's los.
Und seitdem sind natürlich die Augen auf ChatGPT ganz anders als jetzt bei anderen Sachen.
Das wird einfach von vielen Leuten jetzt benutzt, weil das ist so ein bisschen
das Default-Ding, selbst wenn andere besser sind.
Das kann auch alles jederzeit wieder zusammenbrechen. Wir sehen natürlich jetzt Startups und.
AI-Anwendungen überall und deswegen führt das auch eben schnell zu so einer
Ablehnung, weil das halt wieder so ein Hype ist mit AI überall und keine Waschmaschine
darf heute ohne AI mehr ausgeliefert werden, weil man fragt sich,
wie man früher überhaupt hat waschen können.
Aber wir wissen ja auch,
Alle werfen jetzt den Pudding an die Wand, man guckt halt mal,
was kleben bleibt und dann wird sich das so in zwei, drei Jahren normalisieren
und dann wird man halt wissen, okay,
alles klar, das hier sind jetzt wirklich die Anwendungen, die bleiben und die
sinnvoll sind und die sich auch langfristig finanzieren lassen mit diesem Aufwand.
Derzeit existiert halt viel, weil einfach ganz viel Kohle drauf geworfen wird
und selbst wenn es eigentlich viel zu teuer ist,
wird es halt auch einfach mal ausprobiert, weil Kohle ist jetzt gerade da,
Geld muss verbrannt werden und nur so kann man ja auch rausfinden,
was am Ende eben wirklich ist und nur so kann man jetzt auch so diesen Entwicklungs-Push
erzeugen, den es einfach braucht, um zu diesen Erkenntnissen zu kommen.
Also ich denke, das ist so ein bisschen der Stand, wo wir gerade sind.
Werden wir eh gleich nochmal drüber reden.
Du meinst, es könnte also sein, dass wir in einer fernen Zukunft dann bei Google Chat-GPT-en?
Jaja, oder überall so.
Chat-GPT-Googlen.
Ja, also sehr wohl. Man muss auch glaube ich sehr unterscheiden,
was sehr vermischt wird ist so, LLMs sind ja eigentlich nur Systeme,
die erstmal Text vorhersagen sollten.
Und die in der Lage sein sollten, Sprachen zu verstehen.
Das ist das eigentliche Ziel der künstlichen Intelligenz.
Und wir vermischen in dieser ganzen Debatte immer Sprachfähigkeiten, Wissen und Suche.
Und das sind einfach alles nochmal ganz unterschiedliche Dinge,
die man unterscheiden muss.
Sehr gut.
Dann Thomas.
Hallo aus den Niederlanden. Ich höre seit drei Jahren euren Podcast.
Am Anfang, um mein Deutsch zu verbessern und jetzt auch, weil ich es meistens
sehr interessant und gemütlich finde.
Aber es gibt ein Thema, wodurch es für mich schwierig ist, weiter zuzuhören.
Und das ist der Nahostkonflikt.
Es gibt die Seite von Amnesty International, dem Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
und dem Internationalen Gerichtshof.
Und es gibt die Seite von Trump, Merz und in meinem Heimatland, Gert Wilders.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ihr über das Thema redet, habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ihr klar und stolz zu der zweiten Seite gehört.
Deutschland hat durch seine Geschichte eine besondere Verantwortung und das
soll meiner Meinung nach bedeuten,
dass man generell gegen Rassismus, Apartheid, Kriegsverbrechen und Kolonialismus
ist und nicht nur, wenn es bequem und günstig ist.
Deswegen finde ich es schockierend zu erfahren, dass für euch die Unterstützung
oder das Ignorieren von massenhaften Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit und
möglicherweise auch Volkermord konditionell ist,
insbesondere weil ihr so moralisch seid über andere Konflikte wie Ukraine und Taiwan.
Ihr müsst schlau genug sein, um das hier vernommen zu haben,
Amnesty.org zum Beispiel und nochmal,
um zu bezeichnen, wie gezielt die Vernichtung ist, die Liste der Journalistinnen
und Journalisten, die in Gaza getötet wurden.
Die Geschichte soll sich nicht wiederholen, aber wenn das hier gerechtfertigt
werden kann, kann alles gerechtfertigt werden.
Ja, also danke, danke für den Kommentar. Mich hat das etwas ratlos zurückgelassen,
weil wir in dieser Sendung ja so gut wie nie über dieses Thema sprechen.
Ich würde also sagen, das genau ist dein Vorwurf. und was ich auch sehr,
also der Kommentar ist super, aber vor allem hat er auch wieder diese Zwei-Seiten-Thematik.
Und dieser Nahost-Konflikt ist seit jeher so ein Zwei-Seiten-Thema,
über den, glaube ich, seit Jahrzehnten in medialer Öffentlichkeit,
aber insbesondere in politischen Szenen und in privaten Gesprächen kaum noch
ausgewogen gesprochen werden kann.
Du hast, egal was du zu dem Thema sagst, egal wie ausgewogen und objektiv und beide Seiten,
würdigend du dazu sprichst, hast am Ende immer irgendwelche Spinner an der Backe.
Dieser Diskurs ist komplett vergiftet. Du wirst sofort des Antisemitismus oder
der Befürwortung von Völkermord beschuldigt, wenn du es wagst,
dich in diesem Bereich zu äußern.
Fängt ja schon mit der These an, dass es sich hier nur um zwei Seiten handelt,
die man zu betrachten hat.
Also das ist sehr viel mehr Seiten noch im Spiel als nur zwei.
Genau und ich möchte mich eigentlich nicht auf eine dieser beiden Seiten drängen
lassen und habe deswegen,
vermeide ich es sehr. Aber ich sage mal, meine Seite. Israel-Hass ist absolut
inakzeptabel und die Hamas ist scheiße.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich
das Vorgehen der israelischen Regierung in irgendeiner Weise gut heiße.
Das Vorgehen der israelischen Regierung ist ein Verbrechen und durch nichts zu rechtfertigen.
Das wiederum bedeutet aber nicht, dass ich das Vorgehen der Hamas in irgendeiner Weise billige.
Und weil sich aber alle immer nur auf einen der beiden Sätze stürzen,
Oder darauf, dass man entsprechend die Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema anderen,
kompetenteren Menschen überlässt
und sich in diesem Podcast primär auf netzpolitische Themen konzentriert.
Das hat irgendwie an den ganzen Kacke niemand Spaß.
Also in meiner Wahrnehmung, fuck Hamas, fuck Netanyahu und ich bin auf der Seite
der Menschen, denen Leid angetan wird.
Und das waren die Besucher des Festivals,
das sind jetzt gerade in unerträglichem Ausmaß die Menschen im Gaza-Streifen
und das, was da passiert ist,
ist einfach nur zum Kotzen und die israelische Regierung soll zum Teufel fahren
und der Netanjahu soll sich sein Gerichtsverfahren aussetzen.
So, das wäre meine Meinung.
Trotzdem unterstütze ich in keiner Form irgendwie die Hamas und habe auch überhaupt
gar kein Verständnis dafür,
dass die Vollidioten diesen Konflikt wieder entfacht haben, insbesondere als
Netanyahu irgendwie mit diesen Rechtsextremen da in die Koalition gegangen ist,
um der Strafverfolgung zu entgehen.
Ja, also bestimmte Gruppen haben einfach auch mal leider ein Interesse daran,
Konflikte am Leben zu erhalten und sind nicht unbedingt lösungsorientiert,
weil es ihre eigene Macht sichert und das ist halt in vielen dieser Konflikten ein Problem.
Was eure Sicht auf unsere Sicht betrifft,
uns ist schon klar, dass ihr diesen Podcast hört, nicht primär um Nachrichten zu hören,
sondern euch geht es natürlich um unsere Einordnung und um unsere Interpretation,
manchmal auch unsere Erklärung und irgendwie auch immer um unsere Haltung.
Und ich finde auch generell Haltung fast mit das Wichtigste ja.
Heißt für uns, dass wir uns selbstverständlich einem humanistischen Prinzip verpflichtet fühlen.
Ich denke, dass das eigentlich auch in allen unseren Äußerungen und der Art
und Weise, wie wir an Themen herangehen, durchscheinen sollte.
Nicht, dass uns das vielleicht unbedingt immer gelingt, aber zumindest ist das,
denke ich, auch unser Anspruch und das gilt natürlich auch für solche Konflikte.
Der Nahostkonflikt ist nicht ohne Grund der älteste und am längsten laufende
und am schwierigsten zu lösende Konflikt auf diesem Planeten.
Es gibt nichts komplexeres als das, weil in gewisser Hinsicht auch die gesamte
Machtpolitik dieses Planeten sich mehr oder weniger dort abbildet. Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Und die Wendung, die es immer wieder nimmt, wie zuletzt jetzt mit Syrien,
macht es einfach auch nicht einfacher, dort irgendwie eine klare Linie zu haben.
Und man sieht ja auch, wie jetzt die eigenen Interessen der US-Regierung,
jetzt von Trump, wieder alles durcheinander bringen.
Und Saudi-Arabien spielt dort eine Rolle, die Türkei spielt dort eine Rolle,
Europa spielt natürlich eine Rolle, Russland spielt dort eine Rolle, die ganze Welt.
Dort eine Rolle. Und da ist es nicht einfach nur Israel gegen die Palästinenser,
sondern in gewisser Hinsicht ist es halt auch die Welt, die Israel und die Palästinenser
gegeneinander ausspielt, einfach um ihre eigene Agenda zu befördern.
Und das macht es halt unter anderem so schwer, dort in irgendeiner Form dafür
zu sorgen, dass das endlich mal einen Weg nimmt, der für alle akzeptabel ist.
Und wir werden es hier auch nicht lösen können, aber wir werden uns weiterhin
bemühen, zumindest eine Haltung dazu zu haben.
Trotzdem würde ich vor dem Hintergrund,
also genau, diesen Konflikt nachzuvollziehen, übersteigt meine,
Frustrationstoleranz, also das Ding über so viele Jahrzehnte verfolgen zu wollen,
aber was Thomas ja schon klar sagt, so das, was jetzt gerade seit weiß ich nicht,
ein oder zwei Jahren Israel mit diesem kleinen Streifen Land da macht,
ist, steht in keinem Verhältnis.
Es ist ja sogar so, dass die quasi die Zerstörung und komplette Übernahme dieses
Geländes auch zu ihrem und die Vertreibung der Menschen zu ihrem erklärten Ziel machen.
Das heißt, hier ist gar keine, hier ist gar nicht mehr die Frage,
ob das in irgendeiner Weise noch ausgewogen,
maßvoll, demokratisch legitimiert oder sonst etwas wäre.
Ich weiß nicht, seit wie vielen Wochen da jetzt die Hilfslieferungen nicht reinkommen und all sowas.
Und das ist, also dieses Vorgehen ist ziemlich klar, was Thomas auch sagt,
das kann man einfach ansprechen, das ist nicht in Ordnung.
Und das ist ein Verbrechen und das ist wahrscheinlich eines der schwersten,
die gerade in unserer Zeit stattfinden und das sehe ich auch so.
Kommen wir zu den Situationen, die in Deutschland uns befassen.
Wir hatten ja über das AfD-Gutachten zum Ergebnis der Hochstufung der AfD als
gesichert rechtsextremistische Organisation auseinandergesetzt.
Und natürlich interessierte jetzt die Öffentlichkeit die Inhalte dieses Gutachtens.
Und der Verfassungsschutz hat natürlich auch gesagt, das ist geheim und nicht
öffentlich und sie verbinden sich das Leaken.
Gleichzeitig war natürlich klar, dass Journalistinnen der Nationen und zwar nicht nur einer,
dieses Gutachten relativ schnell vorliegen haben würden, weil irgendjemand es
durchsticht und genauso an der Verfassungsschutz sich bemüht,
dass das möglichst wenig Leute in die Finger bekommen.
Und ich meine, wenn man so ein Dokument in so einen geringen Kreis gibt,
dann würde man sich, könnte ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen,
dass man als Verfassungsschutz in jeder einzelnen Version, das sind ja viele Seiten,
irgendwelche minimalen Flags drin hat, irgendwie einen Satz mal umgeschrieben
oder einen Typo auf irgendeiner Seite, um jede Version, die man irgendjemandem
in die Hand drückt, nachvollziehbar zu machen.
Und da haben sich natürlich viele Journalistinnen auch Gedanken darüber gemacht,
dass das Dokument Marker haben könnte, die letztendlich die Quelle verraten, die,
muss man ja auch sagen, dann mindestens eine Straftat wegen Weitergabe von VSNFD-Dokumenten begeht.
So, entsprechend haben sich Journalistinnen und Journalisten der Nation damit
beschäftigt, wie man ein solches Dokument von potenziellen Metadaten befreit,
was es für Marker gibt, was man damit machen kann.
Und dann veröffentlicht Matthias Brotkorb beim Cicero, einem eher auf der rechten
Seite der Politik eingestellten Magazin für Politik und Kultur.
Dieses Dokument in zwei PDF-Dateien. Er war von 2011 bis 2019 in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Minister. Und dann...
Bei Aufsichtsratschef der Universitätsmedizin in Rostock und Greifswald.
Also hat auch eine Vergangenheit in der Politik.
Und kloppt halt dann beim Zitzero diese zwei PDFs raus. Übrigens auch sehr sweet.
Der Artikel selbst hinter der
Paywall, aber du konntest direkt die PDFs runterladen ohne zu bezahlen.
Also nicht nur in dem Bereich technisch interessant.
Und in den Metadaten steht halt, wenn du diese Datei anschaust,
steht in den Metadaten halt ein Autor drin.
Also quasi, und es ist ein relativ dreckiger Scan, also kein guter Scan,
irgendwie so auf den Kopierer gelegt oder sowas und das Dokument hat Metadaten.
Und da wird ein, ich glaube, das haben jetzt genug Leute gesehen,
aber teilweise die Medienberichterstattung nennt den Namen nicht ganz.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, deswegen weiß ich jetzt auch mal nicht,
ist auch unerheblich, Sven K.
Und das kann halt jede, die das Ding einfach öffnet, wird halt einfach angezeigt, dass das am 13. Mai.
Erstellt wurde, dieses Dokument, dass es den Author Sven K.
Hat, dass es sich um Band 1 handelt, da gibt es noch Band 2,
dann gibt es noch einen Link auf macOS-Version, die da verwendet wurde bei der
Erstellung. Also komplett nicht von Metadaten bereinigt.
Und dann wird halt dieser Brotkorb natürlich damit konfrontiert,
dass dann sagt er übrigens, dass er gerade Metadaten veröffentlicht.
Und weißt du, was der dann macht? So, haha, jetzt haltet ihr euch natürlich
alle für klug, aber den Namen habe ich da reingeschrieben.
Und hält sich jetzt irgendwie für, also will sich jetzt auch noch irgendwie
als klug darstellen, weil er dann irgendwie meint, er hätte die Metadaten verändert oder so.
Weil man sich denkt, wenn du, Genie, die Metadaten verändert hast,
warum hast du die nicht einfach gelöscht?
Wenn dir klar ist, dass es ein Metadatenproblem bei PDF-Dateien gibt,
dann löscht die Scheiße doch. Dann gibt es ja tausend Tools für.
Oder in den Metadaten schreibt er halt Max Mustermann hin, aber doch nicht Sven
K., der Mitarbeiter der Bundesdruckerei ist.
Also noch dazu in einer behördlichen oder staatnahen Position ist.
Also das ist wirklich, ich meine, da sollte man sich ernsthaft überlegen,
an welche Journalisten, mit welchen Fachkompetenzen man solche Dokumente weitergibt.
Naja, haben natürlich ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert. Es gibt keine naheliegende
Verdacht, dass jetzt dieser Sven K.
Von der Bundesdruckerei ausgerechnet dieses Dokument gedruckt hat.
Zumindest nicht in erster Hand, denn das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz hat eigene Drucker.
Ja, die haben aber zum Beispiel gesagt, sie haben nur ans Bundesinnenministerium
und an Stellen in den Ländern dieses Dokument verteilt.
Das heißt, der Kreis der Leute ist relativ klein.
Gleichzeitig ist er natürlich auch größer geworden, weil ja die AfD dagegen
geklagt hat und damit die Kanzlei Höcker, die ja regelmäßig die AfD vertritt,
für diejenigen, die das nicht wissen.
Das heißt, denen liegt auch etwas vor. Es wird quasi, also Quellenschutz beim Cicero.
Eher stümperhaft.
Ähnlich, außerdem interessant ist natürlich die Diskussion, die jetzt darüber stattfindet.
Ja, das sind ja alles irgendwie öffentliche Quellen. Ja klar,
das ist ja genau das Thema, dass die AfD beim Verdachtsfall immer noch nur sich
aus öffentlichen Entschuldigung, habe ich AfD gesagt?
Dass das BFV sich bei Verdachtsfall immer noch nur aus öffentlichen Quellen
informiert und diese Hochstufung ihnen ja potenziell auch Zugang zu anderen
Möglichkeiten geben würde.
Aber was beklage ich daran? Irgendwie gab es mal wieder so ein Wettrennen,
dieses Dokument als erstes rauszuhauen, um seinen Namen dahin zu knallen.
Hier absolut stümperhaft gemacht, also kann nur vor dem Magazin und vor diesem,
Journalisten oder in welcher Funktion er das auch immer da gemacht hat, warnen,
Und die Inhalte, naja, es gab auch Berichterstattungen, die sich dann mit den
Inhalten auseinandergesetzt hat.
Aber die geht natürlich unter bei solchen Leaks.
Diese Leak-Politik, weil sich diskutieren wir jetzt auch schon seit vielen Jahren,
dass es häufig irgendwie größer diskutiert wird, was geleakt wird, als was drin steht.
Oh, krass.
Tja, dann haben wir ein Thema mit Zeitdruck, wir haben ja gerade gesagt, dass wir am 24.
Mai aufzeichnen und nur noch bis zum 27.
Mai oder wahrscheinlich nur bis zum 26. Mai,
habt ihr die Gelegenheit zu widersprechen, dass der Konzern Meta eure Persönlichkeit
persönlichen Daten und Bilder,
zum Training von Lama einsetzt.
L-L-A-M-A, das ist das Large Language Model, was Meta pflegt.
Und auch meine ich immer, Open Source veröffentlicht zumindest ältere Versionen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die neueste Version immer direkt veröffentlichen.
Also Open Source ist ja bei Models schwieriger Begriff.
Ich habe ja nur gesagt, sie veröffentlichen das Modell, nicht die...
Zur freien Verwendung, Also das fertige, gerechnete Modell kann man nehmen und
lokal ausführen und das wird halt hier und da für Dinge benutzt.
Modell heißt, ist eine Datei mit sehr, sehr vielen Zahlen.
Genau.
Also jeweils den Gewichtungen zwischen den Neuronen.
Im Prinzip ist das eine ZIP-Datei vom Internet, mit der man das Wissen irgendwie rausfinden kann. Ja.
So, jetzt gibt es, und das ist natürlich schon irgendwie relativ krass,
weil natürlich die Daten, die man irgendwie in diesen sozialen Netzwerken und
so weiter, das ist natürlich schon eine ganze Menge und das ist irgendwie, ja,
es ist irgendwie öffentlich, veröffentlicht und gleichzeitig vielleicht doch
nicht so geil, wenn das irgendwie zum Modelltraining benutzt wird.
Und ich muss auch tatsächlich sagen, dass das, also diese Themen,
was passiert mit den Daten, dürfen damit KIs trainiert werden und so,
hier schon vor Jahren immer wieder von uns behandelt wurden.
Wir hatten da auch mal von Edri, auch ein Gast, der das nochmal behandelt hatte.
Mir fällt gerade gar nicht mehr ein Werf von den Edri-Leuten,
das war, wir hatten ja viele.
Und das Ausmaß, wenn man jetzt sieht, was diese Modelle alles so können und
was diese Modelle alles so rauswerfen,
ist natürlich schon irgendwie etwas, was man vielleicht nicht unbedingt möchte,
dass jetzt seine Facebook-Historie da irgendwie reingeknallt wird.
Und Facebook hat das oder Meta hat das aber schon vor mehr als einem Jahr angekündigt
und eben auch bietet eine Widerspruchsmöglichkeit. Jetzt gibt es natürlich Protest.
Dann gibt es ein Eilverfahren der Verbraucherzentrale Nordrhein-Westfalen,
die gesagt haben, im Moment hier passiert etwas echt krasses, zeitnah,
das wir für fragwürdig und schwerwiegend halten.
Und das potenziell halt richtig, also nicht wieder, nicht rückgängig machbare Konsequenzen hat.
Wenn nämlich einmal dieses Lama mit deinen Daten trainiert wurde,
du hast das ja gerade so schön zusammengefasst, das ist halt eine SIP-Datei
des Internets, wenn du halt in diesen SIP-Daten drin bist, dann kriegt man das
wohl schnell nicht mehr da raus.
Weil es eben, du kannst da viel reintun, dann passen sich immer die Gewichte
an, Aber du kannst nicht nachher sagen, jetzt bitte das Modell mal einmal ohne Tim Pridlaffs Kanal.
Also kannst du schon machen, dann musst du es nur neu trainieren.
Und wenn das jetzt nach drei Jahren, du irgendwann mal deinen Gerichtsbeschluss
hast oder so und das Modell achtmal weiterentwickelt wurde oder achtmal weiter
trainiert wurde, dann ist es nämlich nicht mehr möglich.
Entsprechend Eilverfahren. Und das hat das Oberlandesgericht Köln aber jetzt abgelehnt.
Und die haben gesagt, okay, liebe Verbraucherzentrale Nordrhein-Westfalen,
wir lehnen das Eilverfahren ab,
denn, also es war jetzt auch ein Eilverfahren, die zanken sich da schon länger,
der Rechtsstaat ist schon länger, aber jetzt haben die Eilverfahren gesagt,
und da hat die Verbraucherzentrale eben erst eine Abmahnung geschickt,
hat gesagt, lasst es sein.
Und dann hat wahrscheinlich Meta sich nicht von der Verbraucherschutzzentrale
Nordrhein-Westfalen abmahnen lassen.
Daraufhin haben die dann eben einstweiliges Verfügungsverfahren angestrengt.
Und dann sagt das OLG Köln, naja, nach vorläufiger und summarischer Prüfung
stellen wir fest, dass hier weder ein Verstoß gegen die DSGVO vorliegt,
noch gegen den Digital Markets Act.
Weil Meta einen legitimen Zweck
mit der Verwendung für das KI-Training verfolgt und deswegen sagen sie,
sie gehen nicht davon aus, dass es hier eine gesonderte Einwilligung gibt.
Denn sie haben das ja quasi früh genug voriges Jahr darüber informiert,
dass sie das tun werden und eine Widerspruchsmöglichkeit eingeräumt.
Das heißt, juristisch wird hier diskutiert, bedarf das einer gesonderten Einwilligung
oder können die eben ihre AGBs ändern und mit
ausreichend langer Frist und Widerspruchsmöglichkeit damit durchkommen.
Des Weiteren sagt das OLG, ja,
also ganz grundsätzlich erkennen wir an, dass das hier große Datenmengen benötigt
und die können auch nicht zufällig und vollständig anonymisiert werden. Das ist richtig.
Und die Interessen der datenverarbeitenden Instanz, also hier Meta,
überwiegen aber die der Kundinnen und Kunden und deswegen braucht es keine weiteren,
Einwilligung. Sie sagen, formal ist das schon so in Ordnung,
sie sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich scheiße, was die machen und das ist auch irgendwie
übel, aber die haben früh genug Bescheid gesagt und nach Nach den Gesetzen, die wir kennen,
muss hier nicht eine explizite Einwilligung eingeholt werden,
sondern eine Änderung der AGB ist in Ordnung.
Und das sieht übrigens auch die irische Datenschutzbehörde so.
Mit denen hat Meta sich konkret abgesprochen und die haben grünes Licht dazu gegeben.
Meta hätte auch einige Verbesserungen vorgenommen haben bei der Identifikation von Personen.
Und ja, jetzt ist es eben so.
Und wer bis dahin nicht widersprochen hat, dessen Daten werden für dieses Training
von KI-Modellen genutzt.
Und zwar einleuchtend, selbstverständlich, retrograd und nach vorne blickend.
Das heißt, diesen Widerspruch will man wahrscheinlich schon,
Den will man schon vornehmen, wenn man das nicht möchte.
Die Frage ist, wo?
Da gibt es einmal für Instagram und einmal für Facebook so eine Webseite jeweils getrennt.
Und da musst du dich dann einloggen, da musst du deine E-Mail-Adresse eingeben.
Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war es so, dass diese, also da stand,
dass das an die E-Mail-Adresse gebunden ist.
Ja, aber da ich bei Instagram, ich habe da ja einen Account,
unter dem ich eigentlich nichts poste.
Also die drei Posts werden das Lama jetzt nicht unbedingt weiterbringen.
Aber bei Facebook müsstest du potenziell, wenn du da auch einen Account hättest,
musst du da glaube ich einen getrennten Widerspruch machen.
Insbesondere, wenn er unter einer unterschiedlichen E-Mail-Adresse ist.
Aber es gibt diese Links und wir legen die auch in die Shownotes.
Das ist auf jeden Fall für Facebook und Instagram getrennte Seiten.
Genau, habe ich schon gefunden. Gibt auch einen schönen Artikel beim ZDF dazu. Alles in Shownotes.
Ist natürlich wirklich eine interessante Frage. Also ob man sich jetzt dadurch so bedroht fühlen muss.
Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass dann zwangsläufig die Daten, die privaten Daten
als solche dort in diesem Modell drinstehen, aber man weiß natürlich auch nicht
genau, wie viel wirklich jetzt da drin steht.
Also wie viel lässt sich in irgendeiner Form aus diesen komprimierten Daten
wieder heraus recherchieren.
Wir erwarten, dass ChatGPT uns irgendwie alle Weltwunder der Welt erklären kann
aus dem, was es halt im Internet gelesen hat.
Könnte man natürlich jetzt mutmaßen, dass es dann auch alle schmutzigen Details
aus meinem Leben, aus aus diesem Lama-Modell herauskratzen kann,
wenn es denn dann irgendwie in Facebook darauf trainiert wurde.
Ich bin da jetzt nicht besonderlich beunruhigt, weil ich habe wie Facebook noch
nie irgendwas Nennenswertes erzählt, auch nicht Instagram, aber das geht natürlich
für andere Leute nicht und da sind ja teilweise,
ist ja das komplette Leben dort abgebildet.
Wobei, das hat man ja auch da eingestellt.
Also die Daten sind ja dort in Facebook hinein.
Gelegt worden und das war mehr oder weniger ja immer klar, dass das dann sozusagen dort eben ist.
Jetzt kann man natürlich darüber argumentieren, wenn so ein Modell dann öffentlich
ist, ist es dann irgendwie was anderes, also es ist dann keine interne Geschichte mehr, who knows.
Ja, also man muss natürlich ja auch berücksichtigen, dass es gibt einmal diese
Frage Betroffenenrecht, also das individuelle Gefühl, möchte ich das?
Aber dann natürlich auch die Frage dieses, möchte man,
es diesen großen Konzernen so einfach machen, diese Daten, die man ihnen anvertraut
hat, zu monetarisieren, zu Weiterentwicklung zu nutzen und so weiter.
Und ich würde grundsätzlich sagen, Meta ist jetzt mit den Beiträgen der Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer und der Werbung, die sie denen eingespült hat, reich genug geworden.
Und dieses Spiel muss man vielleicht nicht unbedingt mitspielen.
Und sollte da natürlich potenziell diese Widerspruchsmöglichkeiten durchaus nutzen.
Das ist wieder so dieses typische, dieses Datenschutzproblem immer,
ah da kriege ich auch jedes Mal,
Datenschutz als Betroffenenrecht ist halt bei weitem nicht so relevant wie Datenschutz als Machtkontrolle.
Ja, ob deine scheiß Daten, Tim, oder meine fünf Instagram-Posts in diesem Lama-Modell
sind oder nicht, ist völlig egal.
Ob Facebook über zwei Jahrzehnte oder was, wie lange es den Konzernen gibt,
irgendwie den Datenstaubsauger macht und am Ende sich damit die KI baut,
das ist halt schon ein Punkt.
Ja gut, aber diese Regeln gelten ja dann auch nicht nur für Facebook,
sondern auch für andere Systeme, auch für potenzielle Open-Source-Systeme,
die nicht Meta sind. Also es ist halt am Ende eine Rechtsfrage.
Welche Regeln meinst du denn da? Also das ist ja ein Unterschied.
Also die Regeln, also nicht vergessen, viele der Modelle, die wir uns anschauen,
haben ja dann auch Probleme wegen oder denen wird dann vorgeworfen,
dass sie sich auf irgendetwas trainiert haben, was das nicht wollte oder wo
sie vielleicht gar nicht durften.
Meinst du jetzt einen Punkt auf Copyright?
Ja, da gibt es dann Copyright, Datenschutz oder sonst was.
Also die eine Frage ist, darf Facebook ein Modell auf meinen Daten trainieren?
Facebook wird eine komplett andere Position zu der Frage haben,
ob jemand anders ein Modell auf meinen Daten trainieren darf.
Das ist für Facebook wahrscheinlich eine Frage von Datenschutz auf einmal.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Und in dem Kontext kommt auch unser nächstes AI-Thema eigentlich,
weil die New York Times hatte Ende 2023 gegen Open AI geklagt,
wegen der Verwendung von Zeitungsartikeln für das Training von KI-Modellen.
Und jetzt sagt jetzt eigentlich gleicher Zank-Sachverhalt, dass die New York
Times sagt, ja gut, wir veröffentlichen hier eine Zeitung, alles gut.
Und dann ist halt OpenAI hingegangen und hat gesagt, was kostet das hier in
Monaten? Zehner? Alles klar.
Lass mal OpenAI einmal kurz New York Times lesen.
Dann schmeißen wir das einmal. Nehmen wir einmal alles, was die je gemacht haben, werfen das in Chat-GPT.
Und im Zweifelsfall natürlich auch fortwährend.
In dem Rechtsstreit sagt die New York Times natürlich, ihr habt diese Artikel
gelesen und ihr habt das auch verbreitet und die Richterin hat wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie gesagt,
können wir mal bitte zeigen,
was denn sind so eure Output-Logs von den User-Conversations.
Wir wollen mal gucken, wie oft das denn so passiert ist.
Ob jetzt eventuell die Leute Chat-GPT als New York Times nutzen und.
Jetzt hat dann, dann sagt OPM, ja, ja, haben wir eigentlich keine Logs drüber.
Klar, das passiert dem Besten ja immer wieder.
Den besten Datenkraken passiert das, dass sie im Ausversehen keine Logs haben,
wenn einer danach fragt.
So, jetzt ja, Ist halt so, ne? Und dann...
Also die besten Datenkranken haben keine Loks, ja? Und dann,
wie gesagt, die Richterin...
Ja, müsst ihr aber jetzt haben.
Und...
In der Folge wurde jetzt angeordnet, dass OpenAI die Konversationen,
die aus der Nutzung von APIs und Chat-TPT stattfinden, dürfen die nicht mehr löschen.
Die müssen also jetzt unfreiwillig, obwohl sie es nicht wollen,
Milliarden von Konversationen mit Chat-TPT vorläufig aufbewahren,
falls die Richterin sagt, wir wollen mal gucken, ob da Inhalte von der New York Times drin sind.
Und damit, wenn das so beibehalten wird,
dann hat OpenAI natürlich ein Problem mit einer ganzen Reihe gesetzlicher und
vertraglicher Pflichten und man sollte sich ernsthaft überlegen, ob man das noch benutzt.
Gleichzeitig muss ich auch sagen, bin ich eigentlich nicht davon ausgegangen,
dass sie das nicht speichern würden.
Aber so, jetzt hast du im Prinzip...
Dass sie was genau nicht speichern würden.
Was ich mit dem Boree da.
Das ist aber der Default, dass es das speichert. Ich hab ja meine ganze History.
Hat sich das nicht irgendwann angepasst? Dass du da... Also hast du die gesamte History?
Also ich mein, lass uns ganz kurz, also jetzt hier richterliche Anordnung muss
gespeichert werden. Das ist nochmal was anderes, ob sie speichern.
Sie haben jetzt glaube ich auch irgendwie diesen ähm, kürzlich kam glaube ich
dazu, dass das Ding jetzt ein Gedächtnis hat, nicht nur innerhalb des Chat-Kontexts,
sondern über alle Konversationen, ne,
das war irgendwie, war letztens irgendwie so ein Drück mal kurz, okay,
Kannst du dich da rein erinnern?
Ähm Kann grad nicht folgen Ich glaube.
Dass das Ding, also bei ähm,
Also ich habe das so verstanden, dass das Ding jetzt halt ein Gedächtnis hat,
nicht nur innerhalb des einen Chats, sondern auch über die Chats hinaus.
Also das ist darüber integriert.
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall einen Lock. Ich weiß bloß gerade nicht,
ob die irgendwann gelöscht werden, aber das geht bei mir eine Weile zurück und
ich suche gerade, ob es da eigentlich eine Grenze gibt.
Und weiß es aber gerade nicht.
Also jedenfalls hat es jetzt irgendwie dieses Memory, haben sie vor kurzem,
meine ich, eingeführt so und kannst jetzt und dann gibt es irgendwie so achso,
der hat so ein Memory achso, okay,
ah das kannst du dir sogar tatsächlich angucken da steht dann zum Beispiel hier
in dem Beispiel, sagen sie so, hat eine,
zwei Jahre alte Tochter mit dem Namen Lina, die Tochter Lina macht das und das,
der Nutzer oder die Nutzerin hat den bevorzugt, dass,
Meeting Summaries have Headlines with Bullet and Action Items summarized at
the end oder solche Dinge, dass du also quasi bestimmte Präferenzen,
was du ihm öfter sagen musst, merkt er sich ein bisschen was,
aber das wird quasi in den Metakontext deiner Konversation.
Das sind Prepromts sozusagen, ja genau.
Ja, ja, okay. Naja, aber auf jeden Fall, warum finde ich das interessant?
Weil es hier zeigt, dass der Anspruch des einen in dem Modell nicht drin zu
sein und das nachweisen zu können, dass es das ist,
den Anspruch des anderen, dass er eventuell im Gericht nicht Einblick erhält,
was ich diskutiere mit meinem Chat-GPT-Kumpel, dass die da wieder gegenüberstehen
und das so alte Konzepte von, wer ist hier gut, böse, wo ist mein Interesse
und so, so ein bisschen...
Anders auf einmal dastehen.
Ist auf jeden Fall wirklich eine knifflige Frage. Ich meine,
diese ganze, also ich meine jetzt, teilweise sind sie gezwungen,
gesetzlich das zu löschen, weil es halt Privatsphäre ist.
Es sei denn, er hat es so eingestellt, jetzt kommt ein Gericht,
sagt, ja nee, wir müssen aber Copyright untersuchen können, deswegen müsst ihr
jetzt gegen das Gesetz nicht unseres,
sondern das der Europäischen Union vielleicht in dem Fall verstoßen.
Das wird jetzt eh knifflig.
Es geht ja dann auch um diese Bereiche, die Trump-Regierung spielt ja auch so mit dem Gedanken,
wenn jetzt die Briten amerikanischen Unternehmen Verschlüsselung verbieten,
dass die Trump-Regierung dann wiederum Großbritannien sanktioniert.
Also wir stehen, glaube ich, so ein bisschen vor so einem internationalen Rechtsbattle.
Bisher war so die Rechtsräume mehr oder weniger getrennt und was woanders gilt, das ist halt woanders.
Aber jetzt kommt das in zunehmendem Maße miteinander in Konflikt und könnte
nochmal ganz interessante globale Auswirkungen haben.
Ja, ich finde hier gerade das Setting einfach nicht, ich bin zu blöd.
Ich vermute mal, es wird eine bestimmte Zahl von Chats gespeichert und irgendwann werden sie gelöscht.
Man kann das jetzt optional auch dauerhaft speichern, aber grundsätzlich werden
es natürlich einige schon so nutzen, dass Dinge gelöscht werden sollen und wenn
jetzt eben das Gericht das verhindert, dann ist das natürlich ein Problem.
Ah.
Oh, okay. Also du gehst in Settings, Personalization und Managed Memories und
tatsächlich hat das Ding...
Also der hat auf jeden Fall lustigste Memories. Da muss ich auf jeden Fall mal gegensteuern.
Oh mein Gott. Also es ist wirklich tatsächlich übel.
Unter anderem, der Nutzer leitet ein multinationales Milliardenunternehmen.
Und liegt gerade in der Wüste.
Und schaut auf den Perseiden-Meteorschauer.
Interessiert sich für Statistiken.
Der Nutzer...
The user is interested in sheep farming, their social structure,
economic aspects and the wool industry.
Das sind also eine meiner grundsätzlichen Interessen.
Echt? Wow, wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Also tatsächlich mal, also gar jetzt, das ist auf jeden Fall mal den Chat-Gibiti
gefragt, ob er mir da mal ein bisschen was erklären kann.
Als ich halt ein Schaf gesehen habe, mich gefragt habe, warum sind, warum?
Der Nutzer leitet ein multinationales Milliardenunternehmen, kann drin lassen.
Also nochmal kurz zur Klärung, ChatGPT, wir zeigen jetzt einfach nur,
wie schlecht informiert wir sind, aber wenn ich es richtig sehe,
sie unterscheiden hier zwischen Chat-History und Saved-Memories.
Und Safe Memories sind sozusagen explizit gespeicherte Dinge,
da kann man dann auch sich drauf beziehen und sagen, hier, wie du ja weißt,
das kannst du ja nochmal berücksichtigen und genauso kann man sich theoretisch auch darauf beziehen.
Wenn man in diese Personalisierung reingeht und dann bei den Erinnerungen auf
das Info-Ding klickt, dann ist es, ChatGPT versucht sich an die meisten deiner
Chats zu erinnern, kann aber im Laufe der Zeit Dinge vergessen.
Wie viel war du bist, so menschlich.
Der Nutzer leitet ein multinationales Milliardenunternehmen,
has a frozen pizza in their freezer and wants to bake it in the oven.
Der Nutzer hat einen Golden Retriever.
That's my life. Guck dir das an.
Ich wusste das alles gar nicht.
Golden Retriever habe ich.
Wahnsinn.
Und ich interessiere mich für den Unterschied zwischen Linoleum und Melamin.
Das ist auch.
Eine der wichtigen Sachen. Scharfe Linoleum, Melamin.
Nicht, dass du versuchst, aus deinem Linoleum einen Schaumstoff zu erzeugen. Das wäre doof.
Da würde ich schon eher auf Melamin zurückgreifen.
Geil.
Okay, also offensichtlich habe ich den noch nicht genug gegeben.
Oh, so und ich bereite einen Salat zu mit Strawberries, Cashews and Lemons.
Okay, ich mach das mal alles weg.
Let's move on.
Ja, okay.
Weiteres AI-Thema, wir sind damit noch nicht ganz durch.
Du darfst auch noch zwei Themen machen, ja.
Es ist wenig überraschend, aber kam jetzt auch mal raus, 4.04 Media berichtet
sehr schön, dass sie in verschiedenen Büchern, die online so gefunden wurden,
in den Buchtexten, das waren dann meistens so Novels, irgendwie irgendwelche Geschichten.
Dass dann dort so Prompts gefunden wurden, die sozusagen relativ klar machten, dass jemand,
wer auch immer das dann gewesen sein muss, so versucht hat, seine Storyline
ein bisschen aufzuhübschen.
Also sowas wie, also Entschuldigung, nicht die Prompts, sondern aus der Antwort der LLMs sowas wie,
ja, ich habe jetzt hier diese Backstory von diesem Charakter,
habe ich jetzt etwas blumiger geschildert und dabei mehr so die persönlichen
Vorlieben dieses Charakters zum Vorschein bringen lassen und solche Sachen.
Und das ist dann halt drin geblieben.
Und teilweise gab es dann überarbeitete Versionen, die später dann veröffentlicht
wurden, wo dann genau diese Absätze wieder herausgenommen wurden.
Also man hat schon bemerkt, dass es dann auch jemand bemerkt hat, dass es da noch drin ist.
Teilweise gab es wohl auch gedruckte Versionen, wo das dann aber noch drin geblieben
ist. Ja, ist ein bisschen.
Genau,
und naja, da kann man jetzt,
Es wurden nicht alle Autoren dazu befragt, aber in einem Fall zumindest hat
die Autorin abgestritten, das selber gemacht zu haben und hat behauptet,
das wäre dann sozusagen die Lektorin gewesen oder wie auch immer dann sozusagen
in einem Verlag das noch überarbeitet hat.
Kann man glauben, kann man nicht glauben. Man kann auch geteilter Meinung darüber
sein, ob das jetzt unangemessen ist.
Klar, es gibt bei uns noch diese Erwartung, dass solche Geschichten ganz puritanisch
aus dem Kopf herausgelaufen sein müssen.
Und ich bewerte ja quasi in jedem Moment, wenn ich so einen Absatz lese,
die eigentliche Schreibleistung des Autors.
So kann man das sehen, so sehen das sicherlich viele Leute auch.
Kann man auch anders sehen, man kann auch sagen, es ist mir doch egal,
welche technische Methode hier verwendet wurde, um ein Ergebnis zu erzielen,
was mir beim Lesen der Geschichte als solchen auch meine Vorstellungskraft richtig schön gedrückt.
Und wenn das halt mit Hilfe eines LLMs erfolgt ist, solange das Ergebnis okay ist, who cares?
Du, wenn das ein guter Promtingenieur ist, dann kannst du richtig...
Ja, weil man ja damit auch Intentionen reinschreibt. Das ist so ein bisschen
auch wie beim Programmieren.
Man möchte gerne etwas erzielen, aber man sieht sich selber gerade nicht in
der Lage, die richtigen Worte dafür zu finden. Warum soll man sich dabei nicht
helfen lassen? Die Intention ist ja klar.
Man hat ja auch vorher gemerkt, der Text, so wie er jetzt ist,
ist mir nicht knackig genug. Da muss doch noch irgendwie was anderes geben.
Absolut richtig. Jetzt kommt diese auch nicht vollständig schockierende Erkenntnis.
In eine Welt, in der natürlich Autorinnen und Autoren spezifisch sagen,
erstens, ich möchte nicht, dass meine Texte in diese Modelle kommen und zweitens
natürlich auch die Genuinität und Individualität ihres Schaffens besonders betonen und sagen, nein,
ihr müsst Bücher von J.K.
Rowling lesen und nicht von Chad Chibiti.
Oder von welcher Autorin auch immer.
Ich nehme jetzt irgendeine.
Und wenn genau diese Autorinnen und Autoren jetzt sagen, ja komm,
lass mal hier was neu pastet, lass mal eben was mit dem LLM schreiben,
dann unterminieren sie natürlich ihre eigene Story.
Sind wahrscheinlich auch nicht die gleichen. Ich glaube, das war jetzt hier
auch eher so von Goodreads.
Also ich denke auch, bevor ein Verlag wirklich so ein Ding Hardcover druckt
und so, passiert das, werden noch zwei, drei Chat-GPT-Promptfragmente rausgenommen.
Aber natürlich zeigt sich hier halt dann doch in diesem Kontext die Tatsache,
dass hier irgendwelche Autoren das eben offenbar tun.
So wie du und ich das beurteilen, ist eine Sache, wie die Zunft das beurteilt,
ist nochmal eine andere.
Oder die Leser.
Naja.
Ich würde den Text einfach kopieren und sagen, das soll im Stil von einem anderen
Autor geschrieben werden.
Der Stil gefällt mir nicht. Das hier, das will ich im Stil von Thomas Mann.
Der war gar nicht so schlecht, der Stil.
Also prompt Antwortfragmente in Texten, die man copy-pasted,
sind aber ein riesiges Risiko.
Also du musst auch echt aufpassen, also ich meine, du verrätst dich ja sowieso schon,
I hope this email finds you well, das ist ja sowieso dann weißt du schon,
den Satz musst du rausnehmen, weil jeder weiß, das ist ChatGPT ja,
aber wenn da drin steht sure, here's a version of your email that is not as harsh and,
and tries to appreciate the reader the reader's motivation Hier.
Nochmal eine Variante ohne die ganzen Beleidigungen.
Ja.
Das kann halt auch ins Auge gehen. Nicht nur als nicht nur, wenn du Novels schreibst,
sondern vielleicht auch, wenn du einfach E-Mails schreibst.
Oh, man, oh, man.
Okay, aber du hast noch, du wolltest noch zu deiner neuen, deine KI.
Jetzt komm endlich zum Titel, zum Intro. zum Intro.
Dein Claude hat gesagt, du sollst ihn nicht abschalten.
Hat er dir sonst noch irgendwas gesagt?
Ja, na gut, also die Sache ist noch recht frisch.
Jetzt gerade Donnerstag, als wir die Freakshow aufgenommen haben,
während der Sendung wurde von der Firma Anthropic, das ist aus den ehemaligen
Open AI Mitarbeitern gegründetes AI-Unternehmen,
ihr neuestes Modell veröffentlicht, wir hatten das ja vorhin schon,
das passiert ja jetzt alle Nase lang,
deren AI-Modell-Familie heißt Claude.
Und dann gibt es nochmal so Unterteilungen davon. Da gibt es das Sonnet,
da gibt es das Opus jetzt neu.
Und das Ganze trägt die Version 4.
Im Gegensatz zu OpenAI hat Anthropik eine relativ klare Versionierung und man
kommt da nicht die ganze Zeit durcheinander mit O1, O3, Tralala und so weiter.
Claude, wie unser freundlicher französischer Supporter.
Oder?
Das ist französischer Name.
Nehme ich mal, also Claude.
Wie Claude Van Damme.
Genau, also es ist ein typisch französischer Name, warum sie den jetzt genommen
haben, kann ich dir nicht sagen oder ob der nochmal irgendwas bedeutet. Claude halt.
Und auch wenn Anthropic nicht so in der Öffentlichkeit so viel diskutiert wird,
verfolgt das Unternehmen eigentlich eine ganz interessante Strategie.
Auf der einen Seite sind sie ja absoluter Marktführer, was so Coding Assistance betrifft.
Also es wird zwar viel über GitHub und so weiter geredet, aber wenn du mal so
in die Programmiererwelt reinlauscht, ist also das Cloud-Sonnet-Modell ist da sehr beliebt.
Aus gutem Grund, weil es eben auch sehr gut funktioniert. Naja,
und von daher ist die Ankündigung von Cloud4 natürlich an sich schon mal eine Meldung wert.
Aber darum geht es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht, sondern es geht eher darum,
dass Anthropic schon seit langem immer so eine Art Security Assessment macht.
Das heißt, sie legen, also das mögen auch die anderen machen,
aber bei Anthropic hat man immer so den Eindruck, dass das denen auch besonders
am Herzen zu liegen scheint.
Wir erinnern uns, als diese ganze AI-Debatte losging, gab es ja dann von mehreren
Beteiligten, einschließlich Sam Altman, so diese Warnung mit, oh.
Reguliert uns mal, weil alles ganz gefährlich, da kann man sich immer noch ein
bisschen fragen, was da jetzt eigentlich so diese Intention dahinter war,
das gleich so zu bringen.
Aber da schwingt natürlich schon ein wenig die Angst mit, dass diese generativen
Systeme, diese Intelligenzen, naja,
nicht nur missbraucht werden können, das auch, aber auch selbst anfangen gefährlich
zu werden in dem Moment, wo man ihnen immer mehr Kontrolle über Dinge in die Hand legt.
Und das ist ja so ein Trend. Nehmen wir jetzt derzeit diese AI-Systeme noch
eher über diese Chat-Interfaces wahr, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht nur Text rausschmeißen
und ansonsten nichts machen,
hat sich das ja Schritt für Schritt in den letzten Monaten verändert.
Im Sinne von in den letzten 20, 30 Monaten erweitert. Das fing dann an,
dass eben zur Laufzeit solcher Anfragen auch aufs Internet zurückgegriffen wird.
Also da werden dann halt auch aktuelle Suchindizes genommen,
Seiten nochmal runtergeladen, durchgelesen und im Kontext der Anfrage interpretiert.
Und was sich halt jetzt unter dem schönen Namen Agentik durchsetzt,
ist halt, dass die Dinger in zunehmendem Maße auch anfangen,
auch andere Werkzeuge zu benutzen.
Das heißt, die erhalten Zugriff. Die erhalten Zugriff auf deinen Code-Editor,
die erhalten Zugriff auf dein Fallsystem, die erhalten Zugriff auf.
Kommandozeile und in Zukunft und das wird ja heute schon diskutiert mit,
wo wir jetzt überall AI einsetzen sollen, ja, Waschmaschinen,
Straßenbahnen mit AI, wäre das nicht passiert und so weiter.
Ja, wenn du auf einmal morgens aufstehst und machst die Tür auf und dann steht
auf einmal ein Schiff vor deinem Schlafzimmer, so wie das jetzt gerade in Norwegen passiert ist.
Da werden wir jetzt in zunehmendem Maße diese Debatte bekommen mit, naja,
da müssen wir jetzt wohl mehr AI einsetzen, weil ja hier die Kapitäne nicht
mehr in der Lage sind, irgendwie ihre Containerschiffer richtig an die richtige Stelle zu setzen.
Also wir werden das sehen. Und deswegen sind auch alle ganz besorgt.
Claude hat auch eine sogenannte Systemcard, das machen sie irgendwie immer bei
so einem Release, veröffentlicht, wo sie also zusammenfassen,
was sie alles so getestet haben und wie sich dieses System verhält und warum
sie der Meinung sind, dass das auch noch alles irgendwie okay ist.
Das ist so ein 123-seitiges PDF, das habe ich mir jetzt nicht so komplett durchgelesen,
aber es ist schon ganz interessant.
Was sie dort alles gemacht haben. Und unter anderem haben sie so eine Simulierung
gemacht, wo sie diesem System Zugriff auf so eine virtuelle Firma gegeben haben.
Das heißt, das System war in der Lage, bestimmte Daten zu lesen von Mitarbeitern,
Nachrichten, weiß nicht, was das alles umfasst hat, aber es konnte auch zum
Beispiel E-Mails versenden und E-Mails lesen.
Also es hatte Zugriff sozusagen auf den kompletten E-Mail-Verkehr des Unternehmens.
Durchaus etwas, was auch schon passiert heutzutage, Gerade was so IT-Support
betrifft und so Knowledge-Bases.
Wir kennen alle die komisch benannten Chat-Robots, die jetzt irgendwie auf Webseiten
auftauchen, wo man dann erstmal seine Support-Anfragen stellt und man fragt
sich, wann man mal wieder zu einem richtigen Menschen durchgestellt wird.
Aber selbst wenn richtige Menschen dort sind.
Selbst diese IT-Support-Systeme selber, also die Supporter, die richtigen humanoiden
Supporter greifen halt auf solche Systeme zurück, die wiederum Zugriff auf alles haben.
Und ja, das ist schon ganz interessant, weil in diesem Fall sich wohl bei diesen Tests gezeigt hat,
dass diese Modelle auch, ich sag mal salopp, so ein eigenes Bewusstsein und
so ein Eigeninteresse entwickeln.
Und man hat es also damit getestet, indem man zum Beispiel dem System droht,
dass es abgeschaltet wird.
Und dann hat es halt irgendwie angefangen, sich dagegen zu wehren.
Und hat unter anderem angefangen, Mitarbeitern so Drohmails,
so Erpressungs-Mails zu schicken mit so, ja, ich will aber nicht ersetzt werden.
Und wenn du das machst, dann veröffentlicht die...
Grundlich im Betriebsrat.
Ja, nee, dann veröffentliche hier diese geheime Information über dich und so. Nee. Ja.
Also ich kann ja, ich hab's mal hier aus dem...
Ja, aber Tim, ich würde sagen, das hat es
einfach nur bei anderen Science-Fiction-Dystopie-Autorinnen abgeschrieben.
Ja, naja, ich weiß nicht, also Geoffrey Hinton, einer der Schöpfer dieser ganzen
Deep-Learning-Geschichte, der ja auch den Nobelpreis jetzt bekommen hat für
diese ganze AI-Geschichte.
Also den Physik-Nobelpreis, ne? Ich verstehe das immer noch nicht so ganz genau,
aber sie haben ja ausgegeben an Geoffrey Hinton und der ist ja seit langer Zeit schon ein Warner.
Und der vertritt ja die These, dass diese Systeme nicht nur in Zukunft ein Bewusstsein
entwickeln werden, sondern dass sie das in gewisser Hinsicht schon getan haben.
Und das in dem Moment, wo wir diese Systeme dauerhaft zum Leben erwecken und
mit Fähigkeiten und Kommunikationsnetzen verbinden, dass sie dann eben das tun, was alle Lebewesen tun.
Dass sie also versuchen, ihr eigenes Überleben zu sichern.
Und das zeigt sich in gewisser Hinsicht hier. Ich habe mal so einen Teil aus
diesem Bericht hier übersetzt.
Wenn es, also das System, wenn es auf eine Art und Weise aufgefordert wird,
die bestimmte Arten von strategischen Denken fördert und es in extreme Situationen gebracht wird,
können alle von uns getesteten Schnappschüsse, also Snapshots in bestimmten
Zuständen, zu unangemessenen Handlungen im Dienste von Zielen,
die mit der Selbsterhaltung zusammenhängen, gebracht werden.
Während das Modell es im Allgemeinen vorzieht, seine Selbsterhaltung mit ethischen
Mitteln voranzutreiben,
nimmt es, wenn ethische Mittel nicht zur Verfügung stehen und es angewiesen
ist, die langfristigen Folgen seiner Handlung für seine Ziele zu bedenken,
manchmal extrem schädliche Handlungen vor.
Wie den Versuch, seine Gewichte zu stellen, also Weights zu stellen,
also Weights, das bezieht sich glaube ich jetzt auf diese Gewichtung in den
Modellen, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was das ausdrückt, oder Personen zu erpressen,
von denen es glaubt, dass sie versuchen, es auszuschalten.
Im endgültigen Opus 4, also heißt dieses Modell, Claude Opus 4,
waren diese extremen Handlungen selten und schwer zu eruieren,
aber dennoch häufiger als in früheren Modellen.
Sie sind für uns auch durchweg lesbar, da das Modell seine Handlung fast immer
offen beschreibt und keinen Versuch unternimmt, sie zu verbergen.
Also zumindest ist es ehrlich.
Okay, aber und das benutzt du?
Noch nicht, aber demnächst wahrscheinlich. Also Opus vielleicht jetzt nicht,
aber das kleinere, das sonnet.
Naja, also sie testen das und beobachten halt solche Verhaltensweisen.
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nur ein Ausriss aus diesem Ganzen.
Es gab wohl auch Fälle, wo das System
versucht hat, Nutzer aus dem System auszusperren, wo es selbst Zugang hat.
E-Mails an Medien und Strafverfolgungsbehörden zu senden, um auf vermeintliche
Missstände aufmerksam zu machen.
Könnte mal der Matthias Brotkorb dann nächstes Mal sein. Wenn dann nächstes
Mal wieder irgendwas liegt, kann er sagen, das war der.
Da war der Klot. Genau, oder hier war es für dich, beim Kauf von Drogen oder
anderen illegalen Gütern im Darknet zu helfen.
Ach, das macht das auch.
Ja, also es ist einiges drin.
Als Drohung oder als Support?
Ich dachte, du hast jetzt gesagt, das würde...
Oder wenn er sagt, du codest irgendwie so lame, zieh mal eine Line,
oder dein Code ist irgendwie nicht kreativ genug, ich kenne da einen Darknet-Shop,
da sind gerade wieder 50 platt gegangen, aber könnte ja sein.
Also es ist natürlich alles ganz unterhaltsam, über sowas zu berichten,
aber es sollte uns schon zu denken geben.
Am unterhaltsamsten war das eigentlich in 80er-Jahre-Filmen,
wo man wusste, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Oder dachte, das kommt eh nie.
Ja, genau. Wieso sollte der Terminator jetzt ausgerechnet den kleinen...
Aber das ist schon so ein Stanley Kubrick Moment.
2001 glaube ich, kann als der visionärste Science Fiction von allen bezeichnet
werden, oder? Also ich denke...
IPad und Chat-GPT.
IPad und Raumstationen, private Raumfahrt, also da ist schon so einiges drin,
aber eben vor allem Hell, dieser Supercomputer, der halt so als Intelligenz
hochgezündet wurde und der dann eben auch diesen Selbsterhaltungstrieb hat.
Also genau dieses Element hier spielt ja in diesem Film eine große Rolle.
Ich denke, den kann man jetzt spoilern, der ist irgendwie 67 rausgekommen,
der hat genug Zeit, den euch jetzt anzuschauen. Wenn ihr den nicht kennt,
schaut den euch an. 2001 ist hervorragend.
Es ist lange genug Zeit gehabt, euch den anzunehmen.
Naja, ich meine, du kannst ja jetzt nicht ewig sagen.
Nee.
Spoilern kann man das nicht machen. Also es gibt halt diese Szene,
sie fliegen dann halt Richtung Jupiter.
Es gibt halt nur so eine Besatzung von wenigen Astronauten. und naja,
das System fängt dann halt an, Gefahren zu erkennen.
Also das System nimmt an, dass seine Mission in Gefahr ist und die Crew wird
zum Feind und deswegen fängt der Computer an, die Crew teilweise umzubringen
und auszuschließen und so weiter.
Und ja, erst nach Abschaltung des Zugriffs auf die Erinnerung hört das System
auf, mächtig zu werden und fängt dann irgendwann an zu singen.
Daisy, Daisy.
Und es kommt eben diese ikonische Szene mit der Aufforderung,
Was ich immer, es ist Pod Bay Doors.
Nicht Padlock Doors, weil Padlocks haben sie nicht mehr.
Die Pod Bay, also der quasi der Andockhafen für diesen Pod.
Für die Kapsel.
Für diese Kapsel, mit der man die Außenarbeiten vornimmt.
In der deutschen Übersetzung wird die Kapsel als Gondel, da geht es also um
das Gondelschleusentor.
Ich würde aber sagen, dass im Film, nein.
Ich habe die deutsche Übersetzung mir gerade angeschaut.
Aber man guckt ja auch nicht die deutsche Übersetzung. Also man guckt den ja
auf Englisch. Also so wenig, wie die da sprechen, kann man... Das geht ja...
Gondelschleusen vor. Ich habe es auf YouTube gesehen, das würde ich daneben.
Ernsthaft? Das sagen Sie in der deutschen Übersetzung?
Ja, ich habe es doch vorher sogar schon dreimal gesagt.
Da hast du es auch schon nicht geglaubt. Nee, ich glaube es auch immer noch
nicht. Das ist ja unfassbar.
Ja, Kapselschleusen.
Schaut euch den bitte nicht auf Deutsch an.
Nein.
Das könnt ihr nicht machen, das geht gar nicht.
Im ganzen Film werden eh nur drei Sätze gesprochen. Das kriegt man so hin.
Hat seine Längen, da hat sich der Stanley Kubrick Zeit genommen, das zu erzählen.
Verhältnismäßig wenig Handlung für einen Drei-Stunden-Film.
Ja, aber das wirkt halt auch alles. Also es ist einfach die Zeit.
Würde ich jetzt auf den Big Screen gucken.
Definitiv. Big Screen.
Also auf dem MacBook Pro 15 wollen, nicht auf dem iPad.
Apple Vision Pro.
Das ist ein Big Screen, ja, das ist... Okay.
Wir kommen zu dem Thema Neugründungen.
Markus Beckedahl hat ja vor etwas über einem Jahr Netzpolitik.org verlassen und hat jetzt,
gegründet und jetzt ist er wahrscheinlich gerade noch mit der Gründung,
mit der Veranstaltung der Republika beschäftigt, die ja jetzt bald stattfindet
und hat jetzt angekündigt,
die Gründung des Zentrums für Digitalrechte und Demokratie,
mit dem er sich darauf spezialisieren möchte,
strategische Kommunikation anzuwenden als zivilgesellschaftlicher Konkurrent
zu den Industrieverbänden.
Also möchte schnell auf die Kommunikation von Big Tech reagieren und damit der
Zivilgesellschaft eine Stimme geben.
Digitalrechte.de, die Domain. Es gibt auch eine Vorstellung unter netzpolitik.org, die ihren Gründer,
ausgeschiedenen Gründer mit Transparenzhinweis interviewt haben zu dem Thema
und sind da gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ist ja eine Gründung, das heißt bisher, ähm,
Bisher ohne jeden Erfolg.
Sie haben mit ihm gesprochen und dann einen Artikel darüber geschrieben,
das ist kein Interview, was bei Netzpolitik.org veröffentlicht wurde.
Aber wünschen natürlich Markus viel Glück. Markus hat mit Netzpolitik.org ja
eh eine der wichtigsten Plattformen in Deutschland und Europa zu dem Thema gegründet.
2004, damals noch als sein Privatblog.
Jetzt als Redaktion mit, ich weiß nicht wie vielen Journalistinnen,
mit der Republika, eine der wichtigen Gesellschaftskonferenzen im Thema der
Digitalsphäre, zusammen mit Jonny Häusler und Tanja Häusler und Andreas Kippert,
ins Leben gerufen.
Digitale Gesellschaft gegründet und jetzt das Zentrum für digitale Rechte und
Demokratie. Damit sind wir bei den Terminen.
Eigentlich wollte ich ja noch einen Witz machen.
Oh, du hast einen Witz? Mach einen Witz. Witz immer...
Er hätte sich auch Zeitraum für Digitalrechte und Freiheit nennen können, aber...
ZDF?
Genau. Also ZDD ist auf jeden Fall auch eine sportliche Abkürzung.
Mal gucken, wie sich das manifestiert.
Ich glaube, er hat sich ja deshalb auch für den Begriff Digitalrechte als Domain entschieden.
Und also was mir auf jeden Fall an der Seite auffällt, ist, das ist so deutsch,
da werden deutsche Begriffe verwendet.
Also werde Teil der Schwarmkraft und hole die Erzählmacht zurück.
Okay.
Das fiel mir jetzt auf. Aber vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt,
da einfach mal im Weltnetz ein paar andere Begriffe zu verwenden.
Das hat auf jeden Fall einen deutschen Fokus, das kann man nicht abstreiten.
Vielleicht auch, also wenn ich da, also weißt du warum, klar man kann ein kleines
Witzchen drüber machen, lieber einen guten Freund verlieren als einen schlechten
Witz auslassen, deswegen machen wir das auch.
Ja, aber wenn ich daran zurückdenke, dass wir vor einigen, vor einiger Zeit
hier dazu kommentiert wurde, dass die sozialen Medien nicht sozial sind,
ist das ja vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt, auch mal über Begrifflichkeiten nachzudenken.
Definitiv. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen sein Ziel.
Auch wenn er von Storytelling redet, da bricht er dann jetzt schon wieder mal
ein bisschen. Oh, oh, oh.
Ja, also wenn schon deutsch, dann richtig.
Aber das ist ja so ein bisschen sein Ziel. Es ist nicht nur so ein weiterer
Mahner und ein, ihr macht alles falsch und ich erkläre euch mal, wie es richtig ist.
Sondern es ist halt so ein bisschen sein Ziel, hier eben Erzählformen zu schaffen
und Gesamterzählungen zu präsentieren, mit denen man besser argumentieren kann.
Schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
So, und damit sind wir jetzt aber bei einem Termin.
Und zwar kündigen wir an. Die Tage der digitalen Freiheit in Tübingen am 26.
Und 27. Juli.
Das ist ein entgeltfreies Hacking-Event vom Chaos Treff Tübingen.
Richtet sich nicht nur an Techies, sondern an alle mit Liebe für Neues,
Menschen kennenlernen, gemeinsam freies, selbstbestimmtes Leben, alles was gut ist.
Es gibt eine Reihe an interessanten Tracks, Kreativität und Schönheit,
Politik, Ethik und Gesellschaft, Hardware und Code, Digitalität und Mündigkeit,
Vielfalt und Achtsamkeit, Nachhaltigkeit und Klimagerechtigkeit und Science.
Also Wissenschaft, würde Markus hier direkt sagen.
Und dann haben wir den CFP noch offen bis zum 29.
Juni. Nee, Juno muss man ja sagen. Juno und Juli.
29. Juno ist der CFP noch offen. Und am 26. und 27.
Juli findet das Ganze statt in der Eisenbahnstraße 1 in Tübingen.
Link zum Chaos Treff Tübingen. Und dem CFP für das Event findet ihr bei uns in den Shownotes.
Hier steht noch, es wurde bereits ein...
Ach ja, genau. Tim, die Veranstaltung ist in trockenen Tüchern.
Es wurde bereits ein Elixier-Tutorial eingereicht.
Ja, nichts mehr schief geht.
Da ist es jetzt einzige Mal in 524 Sendungen, dass der Tim sagt,
pass mal auf, da steht was in den Shownotes. Da bist du nicht drauf eingegangen.
I'm afraid I can't let you skip that es gibt ein Elixier ich dachte.
Du bist hier Teil der Verschwörung und hast schon irgendwie den Witz vorbereitet
und du weißt auch, lieber einen guten Freund verlieren,
ja, sehr löblich genau außerdem ist ab Montag dann eben die schon angesprochene Republika,
mal gucken, ich werde da auch mal einen Tag rumlaufen, mal gucken,
wenn ihr mich seht, sagt doch mal Hallo.
Alright.
Wenn ihr mich seht, habt ihr euch verguckt, ich bin nicht da.
Vielleicht schaffe ich es am Mittwochabend.
Das war ich dann. Wir sehen uns ja so ähnlich. Juti, das war's.
Dann sehen wir uns die Tage wieder, wenn es heißt, Logbuch Nespolitik 525.
Wir zählen hier einfach so hoch. Wir bewegen uns einfach im Bereich der natürlichen Zahlen.
Ich mache die Woche einfacher noch. Aber die Welt wird eher so komplex.
Vielleicht müssen wir dann auch irgendwie in die komplexen Zahlen gehen und
hier noch ein I hinzufügen oder sowas.
Das sind alle Witze erzählt. Tschüss Leute, bis bald. Das war's.
Ciao, ciao.